Tabb what's it like to watch your life
flash before your eyes like this it must
be an interesting experience a little
difficult no I'm not I'm not really
comfortable you know when I was an actor
I didn't mind working without the people
but but all the other stuff you know the
hoopla it gets a little I run out to the
barn to be with my horse most of the
time where you shovel the real stuff but
I do I do I do think Ellen did an
amazing job you spent seven years
putting this together thank you but I
also have to give credit to Neal
Koenigsberg if it wasn't for Neal we
wouldn't have a movie and Neal's in the
audience so Thanks one of the producers
well as you know the job of putting all
the pieces together is very very
difficult and so I'm thrilled sure now
Alan this is a story that tab who I'm
gonna obviously ask you about this in a
moment as well but this was a story that
or a large part of the story was held
very close to your vest for a lot of
your life Alan you've known and been
with tab for over 30 years what is it
that made you urge him to tell this
story first in in autobiography format
in 2005 and then more recently in the
form of this documentary well I had
heard that somebody was going to be
doing an unauthorized biography on tab
and I just said look you better write
your own story because if you don't it
will be nothing but confidential
magazine and photo play quotes from the
50s and it really won't have any weight
to it so then I said okay let's get it
from the horse's mouth and not some
horse's ass after I'm dead and gone
because people loved to put a spin on
your life and you know come on this is
the journey and I'm an old man now I'm
84 years old has been a wonderful
journey and I thank God and I just
didn't want somebody putting the spin on
my life and I have to say I think on
behalf I heard a lot of people react
this way this guy looks great for 84
years old right
so what was the what was the process
like of opening up about about this
subject matter a lot obviously this
movie deals
a lot of things your your faith your
integrity a lot of lot of things but the
thing that most people come away from it
the way it's promoted all of that is
about your opening up about your
sexuality well that's so true you know
but I just keep trying to tell people
that that's a thread in the tapestry of
my life and you know it's all about the
journey
you know people so often want to hang a
label on people oh she's like this so
he's like that oh he's like this she's
like that but it's not about I don't
like labels and that was the first line
of my book I hate labels I think we have
to concern ourselves with we are all
human beings and the important things
yes but what kind of a human being are
you and that is major and the journeys
been a wonderful journey there's been a
lot of highs a lot of lows but we can't
forget to say thank you and that's what
it's all about but I just wanted to add
that had to have not have written the
book I never would have been able to do
the documentary because once he opened
up in his book about his sexuality it
really took ten years of talking about
it to desensitize himself to be able to
say when you write a book it's one thing
but getting in front of a camera and
talking about it is something entirely
different which is something he could
never have done had he not have written
his book I just have to interject I
apologize I'm a bad moderate because I
forgot to say they they do not want
photos or video taken as a general rule
with these so I let me just throw that
in there but back to back to the topic
at hand Alan you had a you had a kind of
funny line but actually someone Indic
you know indicative of what's what this
has really been like for you to have
that that this you know where no you
know again the last thing tab wants to
do and that's why I think it's
incredibly brave of him to have done the
documentary because he doesn't want to
sit up here and talk about his sexuality
it's something that's private to him you
know it's something that he was taught
you just don't talk about those kinds of
things and he it's not of that TMZ world
of today where everything is in your
face he's you know I mean there was a
very strict German religious mother
and I love the wonderful thing she say
please nothing for show so what happens
I wind up in show business and I love
one time they were doing an interview
for her you know with her out of Warner
Brothers and they said Oh mrs. galine
aren't you proud of your son and my
mother was so wonderful she said yes
that's very nice but Walter is the
intelligent one yeah so you know well
this is about the the quote when we were
in New York about the people asking you
how you feel I do love the press asked
Alan while we were in New York we just
came back and they said you wrote this
and now how was it doing the you know
doing the thing and he said well tab
opened the door came out of the closet
did the documentary turn around walk
back in I shut the door one of the
things that I'm so amazed at is that you
have very little anger or resentment at
people who made your life not I mean
it's obviously been a very happy life
but they may they tried to make it
unpleasant at times even the you know
it's kind of referenced in the movie but
also in other interviews I've seen you
give you talk about Louella Parsons had
a hopper people that would needle you
because everybody some people in the
business knew perhaps your sexuality but
outside their readers might not and it
was just a kind of needle you and the
same kinds of things we talked that
we're talking about in the film the
Natalie Wood tab wouldn't that kind of
thing but you know what people love to
do if they didn't talk about things like
like they do today and that was so great
I was the end of the studio system
you know we had Jack Warner Warner
Brothers we had Harry Cohn of Columbia
Darryl zanuck at Fox Louie be mayor at
MGM and they ran a tight ship these were
great moguls and you worked for them and
you do your job and if you didn't do
your job just you'd be out and someone
else would be in there doing the job it
was that simple they knew how to promote
films they knew how to promote the
people they were building and it was
quite a different business than today
today everything is so blue blood right
in your face and it's a really kind of
staggering you know if you wanna know
the truth I'm not comfortable in that
skin and it's just been it's a whole
different ballgame but I was thrilled to
be a part of that at the end of that
that's the reason why I wanted to do
this movie because tab had a unique
story to tell you know usually when you
see movie star biographies they're made
because there's some tragedy they commit
suicide they have you know they turn to
drugs and alcohol there's something they
have to overcome tab didn't take those
kinds of Road this is a film that I feel
is uplifting at the end you feel good
about what you know even and he he
wasn't a victim of Hollywood he
appreciated his Hollywood career but he
never blamed Hollywood for anything and
wait one other thing is I think how he
came out the other end hole is when Fame
found him he didn't buy into it so when
it passed him by he didn't try to hold
on to it either and that's that's rare
because usually you know that's a hard
thing to let go off the the horses and I
must tell you this they were the
stabilizing force in my life
they were touch of reality in that
unrealistic world of Hollywood and you
can't live in all of that and I don't
know how you can be really comfortable
in it you have to take stock in what's
happening and be aware of your own
growth mentally physically and number
one spiritually and that is very
difficult to do when all that stuff is
being heaped on you I I would like to
ask tab what is it that as you look back
at this remarkable journey that we've
all just experienced again with you
watching it
what is it personally professionally
forget you know
No Limits that you feel proud as tough
as you look back well I would say the
wonderful people that I've worked with I
mean they're the contributors there
those are the ones that you feed from
and you hopefully can give them back to
all that they're giving you when you're
working with them I mean how could I
ever not acknowledge you having worked
with look
you know Visconti or or or John
Frankenheimer Arthur Penn Sidney Lumet's
I mean you know some radiant Phil
Carlson bill Wellman I mean really great
great people I've been very fortunate
and the actors and actresses I can't I
can't forget about them and Geraldine
page said something to me one time I was
working with her and I said God Jerry
you know everyone loves you the press
hate my guts and she said she grabs a
lot of my armors to remember this tab if
people don't like you that's their bad
taste I thought wow that's pretty nice
so I thought you know I'm gonna apply
that to my life and furthermore I look
out at everybody and I say look just
remember people don't like you that's
their problem not yours